hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 8 video
they totally just threw Red Skull under
the bus it was so much fun just careful
for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet so there's a whole
bunch of stuff going on on agents of
shield right now the main running
storyline is a mix of secret warriors
and inhumanity if you've been reading
the comics if not then don't worry about
it inhumanity is just like a relatively
recent storyline where a bunch of new
Inhumans get created it's the run that
they introduce lash in but it also kind
of dovetails with a new comic run called
Karnak karnak has a solo title if you
don't know he's part of the Inhumans
royal family we got a lot to talk about
so let's start with top 5 WTF number 5
Simmons and Fitz finally get together I
know it's kind of relationship II it's
not the biggest part of the episode but
their storyline trying to bring back
Simmons friend is going to dovetail with
what's going on with Hydra now that's
why Gideon Malick was so excited about
word finding out how shield was able to
bring Simmons back because they need to
bring back their mystery inhuman now
speed which on the number for Hydra is
creating an army of Inhumans for a new
mystery powerful inhuman to command
that's the fish oil pills are all about
Rosalyn was totally in the dark so she
is technically a good character even
though she's been working with the bad
characters I did find it kind of hard to
believe that she had never met anyone
from shield before she know she told
Coulson you're my first you know very
very loaded language there especially
when they're standing next to the axe
that was used to cut Coulson's hand off
I was happy that they acknowledged how
cool Coulson's office is Closen has
always been a collector of things so of
course he's gonna have the most cool
office but on the number three the a CTU
secretly being co-opted for Hydra
purposes has lash and they're going to
try and turn him back into a monster so
that he can be a big part of this new
army of all these new Inhumans lashes
one of the more powerful ones so you can
see how Team Coulson would try to turn
him against like whatever evil army that
hydras trying to create if he's been
calling new Inhumans this whole time you
can see his value now like if there's a
bunch of evil Inhumans you can need to
get rid of them and that's where lash
comes in and even though they had him in
that secret containment unit with the
Hydra space symbol I'm not sure that
they're gonna try and send him to that
our planet I think they're just gonna
try and get him ready for that other
inhuman to come back onto my number two
WTF throwing the Red Skull under the bus
Hydra has had many names Red Skull just
built his organization based on the
principles that we had already been
following but the original organization
that was Hydra or the would become Hydra
was created for the sole purpose of
bringing the most powerful inhuman back
to the earth to rule so if you remember
all the way back to the first Captain
America movie Red Skull creates Hydra
inside the Nazi Party it's almost like
there's a Hydra inside the Hydra Red
Skull was a Nazi that created Hydra to
serve his own purpose within the larger
goals of the Nazi Party now this other
organization kind of did the same thing
that hydrogen and Winter Soldier we've
been here the whole time this has been
the real goal even though we've been
doing these other things based on what
Red Skull told us to do so at the
beginning of the episode when Gideon
Malick tells Ward Hydra is a very
complex organization he was not kidding
what does this mean for Hydra in the
movies because they haven't really
addressed this in the movies yet but my
guess is is they're not gonna address it
that much and Captain America Civil War
they're just gonna let the TV show run
with it TV shows have 22 episodes to
build out mythology movies only have two
hours so the movies are probably just
going to address a small part of what's
going on in the TV show the widespread
proliferation of new Inhumans like
that's what the superhero Registration
Act is all about it's like reading a
comic book with pages that you can fold
out that turn into like much bigger
pages the TV shows the much bigger page
the movies just handle the highlights so
whatever's going on with this super
mystery powerful inhuman I'm not
expecting too much of it to spill into
Captain America Civil War and here's the
deal and on to my number one WTF who is
this mystery powerful inhuman the Gideon
Malick is talking about that they're
trying to bring back who seems like he's
probably immortal if he's been trapped
on this other planet for that long well
the most powerful inhuman that we know
about is Black Bolt I do not think that
this is Black Bolt he seems like a movie
only kind of character if they're gonna
do royal family they might be able to do
lesser people I've heard whispers of
Karnak but Karnak isn't immortal the
funny thing about this other planet
though is that it makes me think about
the real life
carnac it's actually the series of
ancient Egyptian temples it's like the
largest ancient temple that's still
standing that at one time in real-world
history it was this really lush area it
was this big center of learning and
knowledge so if you remember this other
mystery planet that Simmons got marooned
on they said that at one point it was
actually a paradise but then kind of
descended into the chaos that it is now
that's kind of what happened to
real-world Karnak just the area where
the temple was dried up so nothing is
growing there now it turned into this
big desert area now if you guys have
been reading comics recently you might
know that there's a karnak solo title
they redesigned the character that looks
kind of like this mystery character on
the other planet and in the first issue
of this comic story he starts working
with Coulson and Simmons of shield so
you kind of wonder if they're crossing
comic and TV show streams a little bit
but I don't think that that's happening
I'm not expecting this mystery character
to be Carnac I think there's a better
shot of him being the unspoken this is
really powerful inhuman that was black
bolts predecessor he has really
destructive powers and he's immortal and
he's not necessarily a characters that a
lot of people know about so it's not
like they'd have to do the royal family
like blackbolt Medusa lock jaw so you
know some of the more outlandish
characters the crazy thing about the
unspoken is the way his powers work he
can manifest almost any power that he
wants and he stands about seven and a
half feet tall so he's bigger than lash
it's just he's one of the few characters
in the comics that has potential for a
limitless power so he sounds like what
Gideon Malick was describing someone of
terrifying power that they just they
were so worried about that they sent
away here's my big question for you guys
though now that we know that this person
on the mystery planet is an actual
inhuman like an actual person who do you
think that it is do you think it's
something from the comics or do you
think that they're creating a new
character for the TV show what I think
is going on is that yes it's someone
from the comics it's just such a deep
cut that unless you read like every
single inhuman comic that there's ever
been you've probably never heard of them
that way they don't have to burn through
the royal family by the time they get to
the Inhumans movie I definitely think
there are still characters that are
off-limits for the TV show so don't hold
your breath for core royal family
members but what's gonna happen next is
is there's a new episode of arrow and
there's a promo for the big flare Oh
crossover episode I was rich
I'm gonna do a video but just just
because they're probably in the air new
footage after arrow tonight I'm gonna
save that video and do it after my arrow
episode 7 video so next will be arrow
then I'll do a flit arrow trailer video
and then I'll catch up with everything
else so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there's gonna be a lot more Marvel stuff
happening because Jessica Jones drops on
Friday so I'll probably do some new
Jessica Jones on Thursday just in case
you haven't seen it or you're not cut up
you can click here for all my Jessica
Jones videos and you can click here to
catch up with the flash from last night
gorilla grodd so so much stuff happened
in the episode I don't want to give away
spoilers thank you so much for watching
everybody let's have five I'll see you
guys tonight
you